hello and welcome to this video plane
and go with black Maharaj yet to win a
game against I'm so does he know what I
play here or something equally g3 Bishop
gt5 um yeah against this I don't have a
clear recipe I've tried g6 against this
okay let's do it I've had this before I
against align and I lost the game where
he made this slow play very slowly on
the queenside but always had some
pressure we should be too was mostly
producing here but you can pretty much
yeah this is a huge mess up move over
the same they're all kinds of new waters
are possible Quincy to Bishop b2
whatever I would like to play that to do
something actually let's see can I go
with f5 your oasis probably anyway I
don't want to sit around down yet really
the slowest maneuvering game II totally
killed me so let's let's see if I can do
something on the Effra this is a bit
crude of course but it's um I simply
don't want a slowish kind of game
so okay do I want to color b7
Jim Quincy aids look so lame I cannot do
that let's see if I can do this here
look here if it takes with the route 94
could be interesting I'll it is
interesting ok go's 95 that looks a bit
more conservative so what's going on if
I take one g3 let's see let's see if i
take f2 and g3 here min that dance like
super brutal
it will take and go to h2 at the end I
guess hmm doesn't quite work doesn't
quite work but it's it's somewhat close
I would love to get to h5 with the Queen
I'm not sure it actually does much ok I
have to play I have to play something
okay so it just takes everything but now
I think I'm threatening night f to at
least an IDF to King takes Queen deform
it could be on and some stuff maybe
Bishop everyone not sure this is a
threat threat is a bit strong so he
doesn't he doesn't care what I'm doing
maybe correctly so
no isn't isn't this something and Bishop
everyone that's not a threat to say nite
f2 then okay come on let's see if it
takes it Queen g4 king of two queen age
four I can go to III actually I didn't
see that he can escape to e3 in this
position that's bad yeah yeah I didn't
see that he can go to e3 this is the
thing hmm hi morning would have been
interesting if it wasn't for this for
this is three stuff okay now this is
just just not working then I thought I
thought 24th he just goes to buy f-22
III and the king is safe
Bishop g2 Luke f3 this is funny and
threatening look f3 and Queen h4 made oh
but it's only in see this now this is
actually interesting when clip taken on
f3 anyway shaggy goes to each to learn
but I'm threatening this now this is
something that he has to address maybe
ok let's take
Knight takes rook f3 Queen g2 and
winning the Queen hmm
at the end there's some be 70 so check
check at the end is v seven eight is
promoting is this the issue check check
check I look g7 carlucci soon I bloody
hell and then friggin b7 I know I really
got somewhere in this game black resign
hello I know if there was a face they
will say we know some timing challenge
no behalf okay so objectively I'm lost
yeah this is uh this is um I got Gavin
[ __ ] okay so i took here i probably
should have done that quicker because
that's the only only chance anywhere
anyway yeah but it seems the engine at
least is this year it doesn't see
something g 4g takes and now i have a
cookie I've got a checkmate oh wow oh
wow this one made and it's not actually
that difficult check check check
Jim dad look dangerous but I didn't see
it I didn't see it Chuck oh yeah is
always the poem the B porn I have a draw
here but yeah so objectively speaking I
probably should play differently here
this F for business has already kind of
diesem usually um this is a text should
not work our but in a in a blitz game
okay you can you can maybe try and now
this is objectively objectively lost
stop it it's funny it's funny and there
were some some funny moments I mean here
I'm threatening look f3 I mean this
movie is easy to make and makes me put
it that's easy to make now and then what
the funny game okay yes thanks for
watching